[Music]
[Applause]
hello everyone how are you
oh it's great to be here
before I begin to talk about
the whole notion of uh rebuilding
America
I want to talk very briefly about what
happened in Nashville
uh you know uh
we know the the names of the victims
we've seen the initial footage of the
attack
three children
three children dead
all just nine years old including the
daughter of the pastor
three members of the staff school
custodian
substitute teacher and the head of
school
I spoke with one of the
like actually it was the governor's wife
the governor he's telling me his wife
was about to have dinner that night with
her
there's still more to learn about what
happened
but there's plenty we do know
we know that this family's worst
nightmare the family's worst nightmares
occurred
I've lost a child not to that I've lost
a child on accident and through cancer
but I tell you there's nothing like
losing a child particularly the more
senseless it is the more devastating the
impact on you
it's absolutely heartbreaking
and it's senseless you know those
children should all be with us still by
the way have a seat if you have one
they should still be with us
as a nation this is not hyperbole as a
nation we owe these families more than
our prayers
we owe them action
you know we have to do more to stop this
gun violence or ripping communities
apart ripping apart the soul of this
nation
protect our children so they learn how
to read right instead of Duck and Cover
in a classroom
you know we need to act
these are weapons of war I'm a second
amendment of guy I have two shotguns my
sons have shotguns you know but our
states you know everybody thinks somehow
the Second Amendment is absolute they're
not allowed to go out no no an automatic
weapon you're not allowed to own a
machine gun you're not allowed on a
flamethrower you're not allowed to own
so many other things
why in God's name do we allow these
weapons of war on our streets and at our
schools according to law enforcement the
shooter
this horror had two assault weapons and
a pistol
and what in God's name are we doing
these guns are the number gun this is
hard to believe I never thought when I
started my public life that guns would
be the number one killer of children in
America
guns number one
it's sick
and overwhelmingly a majority of gun
owners agreed we have to do something
not just everybody the gun owners agree
this there's a moral price to pay for an
action
last year they came together to pass the
most significant gun safety legislation
in 30 years
it was bipartisan we got it done
and don't tell me we can't do more
together
so I again call on Congress to pass the
assault weapons man pass it it should
not be a partisan issue it's a common
sense issue they have to act now people
say why do I keep saying this if they're
not happening because I want you to know
who isn't doing it
who isn't helping to put pressure on
them
you know I know you see on television
it's not just really the the weapon in
terms of its that it's semi-automatic in
effect
but the velocity with which it comes out
of that muzzle
what it does when it hits the body most
bullets would go just straight through
and out leaving little but it blows up
once it's inside your body
what in God's name what in God's name
does anyone need that for
in America
folks look
let me come to speak to what I came to
talk about
I want to thank Jake for introduction
and mayor Elaine O'Neill thank you for
the passport in the city and Governor
Cooper thanks for inviting me back to
North Carolina I see he should know
better but he's invited me back we've
been doing this a lot where is the gov
there he is by the way
if you had to name the five best
governors of either party in the United
States America this guy is one of them
you really are
and you know why you all know it whether
you're democrat or republican liberal or
conservative he has more Integrity in
his little finger than most people have
in their whole body
what he says you can count on is
completely completely completely
straight we're also committed to this
state you've uh you're you're here on
your wedding anniversary and I just want
to know I sent flowers to your wife I
don't know about you
you better damn well we had time for
that dinner
he has dinner later tonight I'm not
going to tell you the time because you
may want to go to the same restaurant
but uh but uh the fact is that I promise
I'm not going to speak till 6 30. that's
when the dinner is God thanks for being
here today but thanks for your
friendship and you have two great
freshman members of Congress
representative Valerie fushi Valerie
where are you sitting
there you are Valerie and representative
Wiley nickel Wiley stand up man
and they're fighting hard for the people
in North Carolina and secretary Gina
raimondo former Governor as he did an
incredible job incredible job as a
Cabinet member with me and she is
implementing the laws we've just passed
and we're making that you're going to
change this country and most paid CEO
Greg Lowe Greg Greg's over there there
you go Greg
I was doing some photos and a guy walked
through the line said last time you're
here you're here for light bulbs
laughs
I have a lot more than light bulbs now
anyway thanks for partnering with
Governor coupon this historic investment
and this is the largest investment
and Manufacturing in the history of
North Carolina
I asked if I've asked CEOs
I've asked CEOs this question repeatedly
since we began passing this legislation
when the United States invests
considerable resources in New industry
does it encourage businesses to get in
the game or discourage it and answers
Universal and encourages business to get
in the game
Federal investment attracts private
sector investment it creates jobs and
industries and it demonstrates we're all
in this together and that's what today
is about
we're here to talk about what we're
doing to invest in America to invest in
North Carolina and the progress we made
building an economy from the middle out
the bottom up not trickle down from the
top down
that never landed on my Dad's kitchen
table the trickle-down piece progress we
made creating strong sustainable
economic growth we passed the American
Rescue plan right after I was elected
the most aggressive economic recovery
package since Franklin Roosevelt we
passed the bipartisan infrastructure law
the most substantial investment since
President Eisenhower's investment in in
infrastructure roads Bridges ports
airports clean water high-speed internet
and we passed the chips and science act
most significant investment in
manufacturing and research developed in
our history
we used to invest
two percent of our GDP in research and
development
the last 35 years it got down to 0.7
percent but America's coming back we're
determined to lead the world a
manufacturing of semiconductors we
invented semiconductors in the United
States of America
inflation reduction acts the most
transformal the transformational
investment in our climate ever anywhere
in the world put it all together it's a
plan to invest in America invest in
Americans give them opportunity invest
in ourselves and it's working
here's what it looks like across the
country a record 12.4 million new jobs
including 800 000 manufacturing jobs
that means we recovered every single job
lost in the pandemic and created three
million more
instead of exporting jobs
to spending exporting jobs
like to get cheaper labor costs like I
come from the corporate capital of the
world Delaware more corporations are
Incorporated in Delaware than every
other state in the Union combined about
30 years ago under Democrat and
Republican Administration the corporate
America decided to go where the jobs are
the cheapest
and guess what America lost its Edge in
manufacturing lost its Edge across the
board
and we did that for decades now we're
creating jobs we're exporting jobs no
longer American products are being made
here we're growing the economy and today
I announced that since I took office
we've attracted guess this we've
attracted
435 billion
billion dollars in private investment in
American Manufacturing
we announced over 23 000 infrastructure
jobs so far project so far not jobs
projects and thousands of American
communities across the country
and the process for strengthening our
supply chain
right here in America here in North
Carolina we're making chips that go into
electric vehicles these vehicles are
powered by batteries and critical
minerals that we're making and you're
making here in North Carolina we're
making electric vehicles here in North
Carolina that's what invest means when
we say invest in America
before the pandemic supply chain wasn't
something most Americans thought about
it when it said Supply chains you look
at each other with a Blank Stare well
guess what everybody knows what the
supply chain is because the day today
after delays in parts and products folks
experienced everyone knows that's why
it's so important to have to have access
to them my economic plan brings the
supply chain home to the United States I
was asked by one foreign leader to
remain nameless why I was doing this I
said we're no longer going to have to
wait for product from other countries
we're gonna you're gonna have access to
what we do but we're going to have the
supply chain start in America building a
clean energy Future made in America
and that means providing incentives for
companies to manufacture clean energy
technology here in North Carolina and
across the country where companies are
making electric vehicles because of our
investments in Charlotte where you know
albemar is using funding from the
bipartisan infrastructure act to process
lithium and critical materials that
power EV batteries across the state
across the state we're building a
network of electric vehicle charging
stations and we're going to build 550
000 of them across all of America we're
driving up and down the coast or on I-85
charging station will be as easy to find
as gas stations are today and that's a
promise
and wolfspeed is making an investment
that will further strengthen the supply
chain the largest investment in
manufacturing in North Carolina history
five billion dollars of investing
they make the Wafers needed to brew
semiconductors these small computer
chips smaller than the end of your
little finger that power everyday lives
everything smartphones washing machines
hospital equipment automobiles you name
it they're especially critical
empowering electric vehicles which can
use two to three thousand chips for a
single vehicle
and building their Construction and
building and construction whether it's
the size this building they're
constructing will be the size of 38
football fields let me say that again
but we're constructing the size of 38
football fields we'll have 10 times the
productive capacity compared to where
we're standing on today 38 football
fields next door to Chatham County Vin
Fest is investing four billion dollars
producer electric vehicle to use the
semiconductors will speed producers
think about this what it means to our
supply chain into our communities
instead of relying on on minerals made
overseas in places like China the supply
chain will be here in America here in
North Carolina it's a game changer
and by the way American invented these
chips we invented them we're the guys
that came up with it because of this the
space program
Federal investment helped reduce the
cost of creating and marketing the
entire industry that America led as a
result over 30 years ago America had 40
percent of the global chip production
then we've got fat and happy something
happened American manufacturing the
backbone of our economy got hollowed out
companies began moving as I said jobs
overseas instead of products overseas as
a result today we're down to producing
around 10 percent of the world's chips
despite leading the world in research
and design and new chip technology why
is this matter well we saw it during the
pandemic and the global economy came to
a halt overseas factories that make
these chips shut down driving up costs
for families in fact one-third of the
core inflation rate in 2021 was because
of the price of automobiles
they couldn't get enough computer chips
so they started shut down the lines
fewer cars were made workers on the shop
floor were laid off prices went up
because the cars were in short supply
now now we're turning things around in a
big way folks where is it written where
is it written that says that America
can't lead the world and manufacture it
again where the hell is that ridden I
don't know that
no I'm serious think about it think
about it all over the country
semiconductor companies are investing
hundreds of billions of dollars in
record amount of money to bring chip
production back home in Ohio New York
Arizona
not just here
we're bringing the key parts of the
supply chain back to America
companies in every part of the country
are expanding factories and building new
ones creating tens of tens of thousands
new good-paying jobs which don't need a
four-year degree
don't need a four-year degree folks when
I say every job in America should be a
good job
including a fear and fair choice to join
a union I mean it every venture to
manufacture every Venture manufacturing
electric vehicles electric vehicles
batteries would be made Stronger by
collective bargaining relationships with
unions look we're working
ensure clean energy manufacturing future
is also supports the American working
family and good union jobs and by the
way everybody thinks you want to be an
electrician you show up and say I want
to be electrician you go to a four or
five year apprenticeship it's like going
back to school you don't get the pay
until you are qualified fully it takes
four to five years of training that's
why they're the best workers in the
world I asked the South Korean chip
manufacturer I mean why they're moving
billions of dollars to the United States
to build factories here he said because
I swear to God he said because you have
the best workers in the world and the
safest place in the world to build them
listen
I know many of you here in North
Carolina and many of you watching at
home like like the folks I grew up with
in Scranton Pennsylvania in Claymont
Delaware you feel left out left behind
in an economy that's rapidly changing I
get it
but here hear me we will leave no one
behind in this new adventures we're
going to make sure all American workers
or the college agrees without college
degrees are prepared to compete with
anyone else in the world
we're working with companies and
community colleges technical schools
union-led registered apprentice and
Training Program to make that happen in
fact wolf speed is is partnering with
North Carolina Community College and
North Carolina a t and HBCU that
produces more black Engineers than
anywhere in the country to trade workers
and build that pipeline
to fill the jobs we're creating
Partnerships with hbcus like North
Carolina a t North Carolina Central
University here in Durham the community
colleges across the state
they're going to receive 60 million
dollars in American Rescue plan funding
to create new pipelines for good paying
jobs and biotech manufacturing cyber
security and shipbuilding
top private sector companies have
committed to hire at least 3 000 North
Carolinians from a new clean job
training pipeline funded by the American
Rescue plan
will speed
we'll speed investment alone is going to
lead to 1 800 North Carolina jobs the
vast majority of which won't require a
college degree and guess what the
average pay for those non-college
graduates will be eighty thousand
dollars a year
that's almost double the average annual
wage at Chatham County
and then where the new plant is going to
be built
it's not just clean energy manufacturing
next door in Pittsboro the town getting
18 million dollars to keep contaminants
out of the drinking water Northeastern
North Carolina Alligator River Bridge
connecting I-95 and the outer banks will
be replaced with a modern Bridge so
folks headed to the beach don't face the
frustrating delays and detours talk to
one of the 70s Southern hundred thousand
North Carolinian families who are able
to afford high-speed internet because of
our infrastructure law we put it in and
it's available no more having to pull up
to a parking lot outside of McDonald's
to have to turn on the internet so your
kid can do their homework when they're
doing it online
and by the way just yesterday North
Carolina because of your governor and
state legislate became the fourth 40th
state to expand Medicaid under the
Affordable Care Act
the fourth Century I took office
including funding for the American
Rescue plan 600
000 North Carolinians are about to
qualify for high quality Health Care
actually can afford it now for the first
time in their lives so thank you God
it's a gigantic deal it really is it's a
big deal
Focus matters
thanks to Governor Cooper's leadership
putting these federal dollars to work
people are starting to feel the effects
of their everyday lives and these
Investments what they mean now by the
way one thing that's not part of the
infrastructure bill but it's sort of
Health infrastructure we finally after
years and years were able to take on big
Pharma any of you who know anybody who
has to who has a type 1 diabetes or type
2 diabetes raise your hand if you know
anybody
well guess what you've been paying four
to five hundred dollars a vial for that
insulin you need to stay alive well
guess what now they cannot charge you
more than 35 bucks
35 bucks because it cost them only ten
dollars to make
and folks that's not all
you know a lot of people particularly
those on Medicare they have health care
bills that are Insurance bills for their
insurance that is incredibly High so for
drugs so for example you need us you
have a serious cancer problem you can be
paying 13 14
000 a year under the new law no one's
going to have to pay more than 200 2 000
a year for their health care period and
guess what in the process
I'm cutting the federal budget
168 billion dollars you know why because
Medicare doesn't have to pay out those
exorbitant undeserved fees they'll pay
out what they it's worth so folks this
not only helps patients but it helps the
economy all these Investments mean that
now if you grow up in North Carolina and
you go to school in North Carolina you
can stay in North Carolina and with a
good job and you can raise a family and
how many of you before had in small
towns of North Carolina if someone goes
out gets a decent education and the son
or daughter comes in mom I can't stay
here there's no jobs for me I got a lead
or you're going to be able to stay
you're going to be able to stay
and none of this is happening by
accident it's not just happening in
North Carolina it's all part of my
agenda to invest in America American
jobs American innovation pride in our
country dignity for workers and their
families but unfortunately extreme
magnet Republicans not all but Extreme
Maggie Republicans are threatening to
undo all this progress
they're putting our economy in Jeopardy
by threatening to refuse to pay
America's bills not the ones I cut the
deficit by 1.7 trillion dollars in two
years but guess what they're talking
about not paying our debt which has
accumulated over 200 years all this when
you hear these trillion dollar numbers
that's 200 years of debt accumulated 200
years
they want to repeal the inflation
reduction act which means they want to
cut the investments in clean energy
manufacturing encourage companies to
expand and create jobs instead of create
jobs here
they want to seed our Clean Energy
Future to China to make us dependent on
overseas supplies and Supply chains
export jobs overseas and weaken our
energy security
American republicans in Congress all
don't want to cut gut the chips and
science Act stripping our investments in
the Next Generation Science and
Technology like biomanufacturing Quantum
Computing and molecular Electronics look
folks it would mean seeding the future
of innovation and Technology to China
I've got news for you and for Maggie
republicans in Congress not on my watch
we're not going to let them undo all the
progress we made there's a number of
Republicans that feel the same way how
many close to this
I've been determined to make things in
this country again to build American
manufacturing capacity to make sure
we're never and again for a position
like we were during the pandemic
we're relying on other countries to make
things that we need at home to make
anything
folks some folks didn't believe we could
do it but I've made a note made no bones
about it
I've said for a long time and I mean
this from the bottom of my heart
if we invest in America we can change
the country's future
30 years ago I'll say it again we
invested two percent of our entire GDP
in research and development
by the time I came to office that was
under 10 I'm not mistaken was seven
tenths of one percent
we're turning that around
we're proven it's never been a good bet
to bet against America
I've never been more optimistic about
our country's future
we just need to remember who we are
we're the United States of America there
is nothing nothing beyond our capacity
when we act together virtually nothing
God bless you all and may God protect
our troops thank you thank you
[Music]